[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
don't listen to the noise
[Music]
every one of them are [ __ ] liars
every last one of them that are
naysayers of this program and anyone
bitching
anyone bitching about how unfair it is
oh it's so unfair
where the [ __ ] were you asleep or have
you been asleep the last 30 40 years get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] it's
unfair
give me a break i'm talking about this
student loan net relief program that joe
biden rolled out yesterday the only
decent argument that i've heard against
this thing the only one
is rather the president in the united
states actually has this power or not i
think that's a debate to have the
problem is is we can't actually have
that debate until we find out so we're
going to find out whether the president
united states has this power or not or
the courts think they have he has this
he or she the president united states
has this power not
i mean that's that's a reasonable
starting point for a debate for this but
the
but i oh it's so unfair give me a
[ __ ] break you whiny little [ __ ]
every last one of you and i'm not
talking about just the people who are
like oh i got ppp money millions of
dollars of ppp money didn't have to pay
it back
but it's unfair that average americans
get ten 000 of student loan debt and
then [ __ ] [ __ ] who
went to school
20 25 years ago
and don't understand that 10 000 25
years ago hell that pay for the majority
of your [ __ ] tuition wouldn't even be
a drop in the bucket now you stupid
bastards they haven't been to school in
20 years and they're bitching about
they're bitching about people getting
tuition paid for i worked really hard i
worked really hard to pay it off yeah so
okay
great
now what what i mean what do you
it's almost like they heard yesterday
that joe biden is writing ten thousand
dollar checks to people that it's not
that is not even close to what is
happening
not even close to what is happening this
program is hell of a lot more
comprehensive than people just than the
government just writing checks to people
and frankly if we're talking about the
government writing checks to people i'm
not really even against that
for average americans to get checks
because they need assistance what the
[ __ ]
when in the [ __ ] did we have so many
goddamn [ __ ] in this country and i
guess we've always had these [ __ ] in
this country it just would grandpa poopy
pants being them [ __ ] in chief they
just crawled out underneath their
[ __ ] rocks then they got permission
to just be complete [ __ ]
they're just [ __ ] [ __ ] this it's
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] they didn't
want to put a [ __ ] mask on when they
went into a store so they didn't get
everyone sick during the pandemic same
[ __ ] same [ __ ] same
you
you whiny little [ __ ] [ __ ]
bitching about how it's unfair
that someone gets economic relief
i told you yesterday that this is this
really
joe biden doing this
there's a lot of different reasons why
history is going to look well upon his
at least his first two years in office
because joe biden is doing something
here that most presidents wouldn't do in
this time in this moment when there's
record low unemployment wages are on the
way up
again any president who wanted to not
have to
play with this politically could just
say
man
everything's good now we'll wait to see
what happens next year
we're we're close to an election you
know they could do [ __ ] like that not
not not brandon dark brandon's like
let's let's torch this [ __ ]
and really if you look at the plan
he's the plan is eviscerating all
naysayers it really is this inflation
[ __ ] what are you talking about
inflation the [ __ ] out of here i heard
someone this morning say oh well
tuition prices are going to go up
colleges are going to raise tuition did
you even read or listen to what the [ __ ]
they said yesterday
about this plan if this plan is
implemented the way they want it the
colleges could raise the tuition to a
gazillion dollars
and it won't [ __ ] matter
the discretionary spending
for someone is cut in half for their
minimum payment from ten percent to five
percent so now your minimum payment is
based on your discretionary spending
for your income and it's cut in half
okay number one
dummy number two
you either have most people are gonna
have a 20-year rule
where you pay for 20 years that's it or
you pay for 10 in some cases
and that's it
so it's based on your income and and you
pay for a certain amount of years who
gives a [ __ ] what the college charges
if that debt is relieved from the from
the fed the federal government is
relieving that debt after a certain
amount of number of years
and
at a minimum discretionary payment of
five percent
how in the [ __ ] how in the [ __ ] don't
these how in the i just can't understand
it how you don't [ __ ] think before
you [ __ ] start talking about this
[ __ ] and saying dumb [ __ ] about how in
college tuition's gonna inflate who
gives a rat's ass what the colleges
charge because with this plan
with this plan what it forces this
country to do
is to have a debate about how good
colleges really are
and how much a college degree actually
matters that's a debate we need to have
i i believe that's a debate we need to
have
continuing education in higher education
is a problem in this country because
it's predatory
and yesterday if this plan stands part
of that predatory
component of higher education gets
dunked in the trash
because now now universities are relying
upon their [ __ ] students their
customers who are going to pay back the
loan to seek high-paying jobs
five percent of their discretionary
yearly income
got it are you following for 20 years in
some cases 10 with community colleges
and pell grants and that's the other
thing that's the other thing that i'm i
i can't [ __ ] i can't
tell you how [ __ ] frustrating it is
for these people to say it's not fair
it's not fair i i worked hard and i got
a good job and i paid off my [ __ ] do you
know what a pell grant is number one a
pell grant isn't even really a grant
that's all [ __ ]
that's just a fancy name they gave those
[ __ ] loans
oh we're gonna grant you the right to
have a loan that you're gonna have to
pay back the rest your life
congratulations the [ __ ] out of here a
grant is a grant
where they grant you money not alone
jesus [ __ ] christ people
we are just a country of [ __ ]
now here's the thing
ultimately in the end
joe biden again
is gonna play [ __ ]
chess with politics here
why everyone else is playing checkers it
seems jesus christ you have people
people who are claimed to be smart on tv
on the media this morning
saying oh this is going to raise the
price of tuition colleges are going to
raise their price who cares as [ __ ]
that's the point
the point is is it's now capped
he capped him it now again if this if
this plan stays in place because it can
be challenged
that's the other thing that they keep he
did this out of nowhere he just woke up
yesterday and decided this is what he
want get the [ __ ] out of here
people have been yelling and screaming
since he got elected about this student
debt thing frankly to the point to where
it was bad politically to even talk
about it
yeah i said it
but now joe biden has put us in a
position to politicize the absolute [ __ ]
out of this and that's what we should do
you know here on the tony michael's
podcast we want to politicize everything
because i'm going to show you a video of
a [ __ ]
four-headed fascist down in florida
wow four-headed fascists down in florida
who wants to have his own little fascist
courts in congress yeah scary-ass [ __ ]
some wild [ __ ] down there in florida
happening on matt gatz's forehead
but we gotta do whatever we can to make
sure that people who set policy
people who think
about policy for longer than what it
takes to tweet it
set policy like joe biden in his
administration
now this product
of this bill isn't exactly 100 joe biden
i mean he gets a lot of credit he is the
president of the united states
but they've been working on this
[ __ ] for a long time they've
been trying to figure out how to how to
keep his campaign promise of ten
thousand dollars but not just keep the
campaign promise of ten thousand dollars
that's not how the administration works
that's not how joe biden works
how he works is how can we make sure
that they can't stop it number one we
make it to where it is permanent number
two and
and it's good
politically and ultimately the main goal
is to help the american people how can
we do all those things and they took
again
it's been a year and a half since
they've been working on this program and
yesterday they rolled it out and the
media don't listen to them
stop [ __ ] turn that [ __ ] off
turn that [ __ ] [ __ ] off
those [ __ ] most of the ones
that are mad in the media are the ones
that are making over 125 000 or they
already paid off their student debt
because they went to college 25 years
ago 30 years ago stop listening to those
dumb [ __ ]
stop it's not worth it they ain't they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about
they just don't they don't know what
they don't know
what average americans have to deal with
they don't know that there's people out
there that are saddled with this [ __ ]
debt
did you listen to what joe biden said
yesterday
he said one third one one-third of all
federal student loan debt
one-third
does not have a college degree behind it
it doesn't it doesn't have a college
degree behind it and it doesn't matter
why [ __ ] it doesn't matter
you can whine and complain and [ __ ] and
moan all you want
but ultimately this is good for the
american people not just not just the
people who are going to receive this
benefit either
not just those folks
we are going to have more discretionary
spending
from folks who are higher earners even
think about this for a second
folks that are higher earners who have
degrees who make over 125 000 are gonna
receive the benefit
of a five percent minimum payment for 20
years
of their discretionary spending which
means we get five percent of their
discretionary spending possibly back
into the economy
how in the [ __ ] is that bad in our
capitalist society it's not
we just relieved and and gave the the
economy a push a boost
and it's gonna cause inflation oh my god
college prices are going to go up as if
they weren't already
this is a bunch of this is just a sack
full of horseshit all of it
because frankly when this starts to
happen if we if this executive order
stands if this plan for debt relief
stands the way that the way that the
administration has written it
politically this is great too
because if you think about it and i'm
not sure exactly the statistics and the
demographics but my guess is
my guess is folks
my guess is
is that because this is how it always
happens
in our [ __ ] country
because the privileged are the ones who
receive these loans
and i'm talking about the rural white
people
trump supporters
that's right that's right trump
supporters are going to receive a [ __ ]
ton of debt relief here
a [ __ ] ton
look
most people know in this country and
maybe people don't
even if you have a college degree even
if you have a college degree in a lot of
rural areas in this country where trump
wins and
trumps the maga king
most of those people even having college
degrees do not make 125 000 a year they
do not
with a college degree i'm not [ __ ]
you they do not
most of them who have a college degree
do not make 125 000
there's going to be a lot of folks a lot
of folks
who do not support joe biden who were
going to receive
debt relief
and if they don't apply for the debt
relief
then they have chosen not to apply and
to pay that ten thousand dollars which i
think you should have the choice
if you want to pay back the ten thousand
dollars and you don't want to take the
government handout
the debt relief fine what [ __ ]
go ahead
pay it on your own
i mean at the end of the day it doesn't
make a difference
if you choose individually now most
people are going to
and a lot of people are going to [ __ ]
take the debt relief and say they didn't
take it why not they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyways
america is a sack for [ __ ] that's
what we're learning here the the last
five years
especially with this particular instance
well it's unfair because because 20
years ago i went to school and i had to
pay for my loans so everyone from here
on out should have to should have to do
the same thing i did
jesus [ __ ] christ
it's sad it really is sad
that the american people didn't look at
what happened yesterday and go you know
that's a pretty sweet deal
that's a pretty sweet deal for people
who can't afford to pay back their debt
it's an arm up for them
and if we pull them up in the economy by
god our economy will be better
why don't we why the [ __ ] don't these
morons understand
this they don't get it
it's the same reason why they [ __ ]
miscalculated about roe v wade
an overturning row with dobbs in
louisiana total miscalculation and i
believe they're miscalculating on this
student debt program
total miscalculation even the naysayers
on the left like nina turner that
[ __ ] idiot yeah i said it if you like
nina turner just [ __ ] turn me off i
don't give a [ __ ] turn me the [ __ ] off i
can't stand her her [ __ ] she's a
trumper she's a [ __ ] trumper who
wears a bernie sticker that's right
i'm sick of that [ __ ] i'm sick of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] on the left
you talking about you talking about how
you're go i'm just i'm not even gonna be
quiet about it anymore [ __ ] her
something this all or nothing [ __ ]
well if we don't get all of it then we
don't want it 45 [ __ ] percent 45 nina
turner
45 [ __ ] percent of federal student
debt gone 45
you're getting what you want dummy
pluck your head out of your ass you
[ __ ] uh autocrat
thinking that people have magic wands
because really honestly that is the real
debate to have here with this student
loan debt relief program
is can the president of the united
states actually do this
that's the debate
every american should be like this is a
great plan
i mean really it could go further but
this is fantastic for not just not just
folks who are struggling with their debt
but everyone because this is going to
[ __ ]
this is not this is going to cause dis
inflation
it's going to free up discretionary
spending to spend in the economy
it's gonna cause inflation you're a
dumbass
literally literally the american people
don't even know the fundamentals of the
[ __ ] country they live in it's
ridiculous
but you have the right to be stupid in
this country you definitely have the
right and liberty to be a dumb [ __ ]
but nina turner and the naysayers on the
left the all or nothings
well we want it all we want nothing oh
okay so that's a great idea let's not
give anybody anything because
you don't get what you want you can't be
an authoritarian have a magic wand
but again that's the real debate here
can will this work and what i mean is
not will the program work because really
the details that are laid out in this
program do a lot of different things
and they really cause the universities
to rethink how they're going to [ __ ]
how they're going to make money
on the backs of america on
back to hard-working americans
the federal government is going to force
universities to really rethink what how
they're going to charge tuition they're
really gonna [ __ ] rethink it
and also what their [ __ ] programs
their degree programs and their job job
placement is i bet the universities and
colleges all around the country this
morning are saying man if this stands
we're gonna have to hire a whole
department of people just to [ __ ]
have job placement for for our students
we need them to get really good [ __ ]
jobs
that is the [ __ ] job of the college
in the university that is the [ __ ]
job that's the whole goddamn point
that's why we've been [ __ ]
indoctrinated to think that higher
education means college degree which
that's not what it means
but that's the debate we need to have
and the other debate is the can a
president do this
because really honestly if joe biden
wanted to just test to see if if he
could do this or not he could have just
done the 10 thing across the board put
the income cap on it went on about his
way
but he didn't do that on purpose
because he wanted to make sure he
fundamentally changed the way that
people think about college and tuition
and student loans in this country and
this plan does that it makes you
fundamentally have an argument about
something now
people have dumb [ __ ] arguments about
this [ __ ] because this [ __ ] that's based
on no kind of reality at all
which is typical with these
[ __ ] typical
but it goes back to the real debate and
i think this is this is the thing that
we we will see is does the president
have this power i don't know we don't
know if they do or not we don't know
this has never really been done in this
way before
so we'll see we'll see if they have this
power if they do have this power if the
president does have this power i would
say the next president is going to have
to go a step further
because that's the other oh it's unfair
because now i i'm not in college yet and
i haven't don't have debt yeah so
what the [ __ ] that got to do with
anything we can't eliminate debt that
doesn't exist
that's not a thing
it's not a thing but there's still
benefits that benefit people who
actually occurred debt from now from
here on out a benefit that people that
didn't get it
from years ago they didn't have the
opportunity to only pay 10 or 20 years
and their loan be done and over with
well
frankly 40 50 years ago you didn't have
to pay on it for [ __ ] 20 years
because the bill wasn't that stiff
and a lot of it wasn't even federally
subsidized most of it was unsubsidized
that's the other thing that a lot of
these [ __ ] out there yelling
and screaming about this [ __ ] don't
aren't [ __ ] saying
is this a federal subsidized loans not
unsubsidized and most people who went to
college more than 25 years ago the hefty
part of their [ __ ] college debt was
unsubsidized
trust me i know
[ __ ] out of here with this nonsense is
[ __ ] you people just
[ __ ] got your head up your ass
stop
stop it you [ __ ]
pluck it out
wash your face off wash the [ __ ] off
your face
come to your senses and realize what
this thing really is
and you will see that it's good for
everyone in this country not just the
people who still have debt not just the
people who still have federal subsidized
debt not just the people who who
currently have debt and haven't gone to
college and already went to college it
benefits everyone and the point is the
conversation to move this forward
this is how we progress this is called
um oh what's that word democracy
right in front of your [ __ ] face this
is democracy this is what it is
which brings up a great point
maybe maybe maybe just maybe we the
people the government it's us it's our
government by the way
we're the government
we're a constant democratic
constitutional republic
which means we the democracy we the
government get to elect our
representatives who go represent us when
they're voting
on the policies that we want them to
have and there is term limits by the way
we get to fire them every [ __ ] two
years in the house and every six years
in the senate and every four years in
the in the executive branch so yeah we
are the government and we get to hire
and fire those [ __ ]
that's we need to start looking at it
that way
and anyone out there yelling and
screaming about it's unfair
for americans who are struggling to pay
their [ __ ] college debt who could be
participating
more actively in the economy which rises
all [ __ ] boats here in this country
which makes our economy stronger
makes our markets stronger
i'm not talking about the stock markets
i'm talking about housing markets i'm
talking about job markets labor markets
all kinds of markets out there
that are that re affect real american
people
most american people don't [ __ ]
benefit from the goddamn stock market
and if they do their retirement stuff in
there and it's a bunch of rich people
taking their [ __ ] money
to make them think that oh yeah you're
gonna get rich
most americans don't actually want to be
completely wealthy or they shouldn't
they should want to maintain a lifestyle
that they can maintain that they want to
have
greedy [ __ ]
[ __ ] but we can stop this stuff we
can stop electing we can stop [ __ ]
supporting people
who are [ __ ]
we can stop doing that
and i know there's going to be a lot of
democrats are going to be out against
this because a lot of their constituent
base are the [ __ ] i'm talking about
and that's the thing we have to be
careful about here
we have to tread lightly because we got
to win some of these races right
we got to have some of these policy
makers that will not only support biden
in his
effort to try to relieve
the cost of universities in college and
higher education on americans in this
country so they can get ahead in the
economy but also some of those policy
changes because that's the most
important component
of this whole thing
is if we have a debate in our democracy
ours in our government
then what we can do is get enough people
to be policy makers to actually make a
policy that would be better than this
plan altogether would make this plan
irrelevant
think about think about
if the federal government we put policy
makers in jobs to set policy
real [ __ ] serious people not [ __ ]
boneheads and social media influencers
like matt gast lauren bobert and and
swattery taylor green
[Music]
swattery taylor green
not [ __ ] like that
i'm talking about people who are serious
about setting policy for their
constituents
if we do that
if we the people do that we consider
these people as policy makers and
they're going to be serious about it
and talking about american people in the
communities like joe biden has been
doing
betto is talking about
uh fetterman warnock kelly is talking
about then what we can do is we can set
policy that is 10 times better
and 10 times the plan that this biden
debt relief package and make it [ __ ]
irrelevant
make it irrelevant
make higher education affordable and i'm
not just talking about college and
universities because that's another
thing that we need to figure out and
have a discussion in this country
not everyone should go to a university
and get a degree
there's plenty of jobs out there in the
trades
and they're good paying jobs good
careers people like those careers
and we
we should focus on americans the
american people and our communities if
we do that if we do that which i believe
that this is what this package does now
someone some [ __ ] is gonna challenge
it that's right some asshole's gonna
challenge it try to take it to court and
try to get it undone because they're an
[ __ ]
it's to be very difficult for them
because the administration has thought
about this plan for a long time they did
a very good job of designing this plan i
think and it's going to be very hard for
someone to undo what they've done here
but we're going to find out we're going
to find out in the real debate whether a
president of the united states can
actually do this or not
but what you need to do is you need to
engage in your democracy
don't let anyone [ __ ] you on this
don't let them [ __ ] you on this you
don't need to be bullshitted they're
probably [ __ ] in the comments right
now i don't know i haven't been paying
attention are they bullshitting in the
comments
are people bullshitting here i don't
know
but if you're bullshitting in the
comments
good morning
good morning and well welcome to the
tony michaels podcast you found out this
morning that we air every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern
11 central 9 pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and simulcast from the midas
touch facebook page welcome all you
naysayers you're going to get an earful
today you're going to get an earful
today now someone says nope there's 90
naysayers and yeah they are they all
left
everyone everyone here is not a naysayer
i guess i don't know maybe maybe not
maybe so who knows who can tell when i
started calling them [ __ ] maybe they
left see you [ __ ] alright everybody
thanks for sticking around thanks for
coming to this thursday
of the tony michaels podcast don't
forget to subscribe while you're here to
the tony michaels podcast youtube
channel
that would help us out a lot also go
follow us on twitter at tony michaels
pod today's thursday you know what
thursday is
we get to vote
vote for bone end of the week every
single friday for all you new listeners
out there we do bonehead of the week in
the second hour
of the friday show you vote you decide
who is the bonehead of the week me and
my co-host gabe sanchez break it down so
don't forget to vote this evening for
bonehead of the week on twitter or on
youtube you can also download every
single episode of the tony michaels
podcast on apple spotify and google
leave us a great review while you're
there and i would fail to mention this
if i don't i would i'd be a failure if i
didn't mention this we have the doubt me
merch going on right now everyone get
your doubt me merch store not the
tonymichaels.com
everyone was waiting for this merch it
is there it's in the store just go to
store.dtonymichaels.com the moderators
will probably be posting this link
throughout the show in the live chat
don't forget to go to you can also go to
thetonymichaels.com
and we have that link there you can also
support free pro-democracy speech
today with the link down below support
dot tonymichaelspod.com or you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
that link is at the very top of that
page or
if you're fancy enough and you know how
to use a qr code you can do that as well
and i'm sure i'm sure our our great
moderators
will be putting the links in the live
chat thank you very much to the
moderator show them some love today
everyone stick around don't go anywhere
we will be right back right after this
break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
yours
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live love and blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome
back to the show thanks for sticking
with us through the break
[Music]
how much more do i have to beat this
student loan stuff to death
i don't know
i don't know we'll find out i really i
really don't even like talking about
that this much but then
seeing that he did what he did yesterday
and now we have all the naysayers out
there running around oh it's unfair it's
unfair oh people working hard and blah
blah you think the people who are gonna
receive this debt relief are lazy people
you're a dumb [ __ ]
it has nothing to do there's no work
component to it at all none
there's no work component it's not like
well if you're if you got a college
degree and you're paying debt and you
ain't got a job well then we're going to
give you the money that's not at all
though that's not even the [ __ ]
that's not even the actual structure of
it dummy
frankly frankly the people who don't
have degrees
and have college debt
who aren't [ __ ] receiving the benefit
of the college they went for that they
took the [ __ ] loan those are the ones
that are gonna have the most relief and
it's the easiest kind of relief because
it's not a lot per person it's not and
gabe we talked about this yesterday we
talked about this a lot but yesterday
but you know i guess i should have
really predicted that the naysayers
would be out and about
yeah well it's easy it's it's it's very
easy for
people who
who don't understand
kind of the the one the
the proposed or or the the planned
kind of relief and aid that will be
given by wiping
these debts off the table right off the
books
for people who don't understand to make
assumptions to make accusations about it
right like
to assume oh well if we're removing this
debt from the books then that means that
i as a taxpayer have to pay more or it's
going to be a higher inflation rate and
these things are not true
right we talked about yesterday which is
like this isn't this you know i think
you just mentioned it a moment ago this
isn't injecting
money into the economy right no one's
getting 10 dollar checks right this is
saying hey look you you don't have to
pay this amount and you actually have to
apply for it too it's not just gonna be
automatically wiped right like you right
if these they're gonna they're gonna
have to apply each individual loan the
fed isn't just going to go and go up all
this debt's gone right someone's going
to have to prove that right and it's
because it has no stipulations with
income right and and i look at the same
way that like
if our country worked in an efficient
way we would never have to file for
taxes the government knows what we owe
because when we file and they go nope
you didn't do it right it's like why
didn't you just tell me in the first
place it's the same way here right they
know what loans you have when it comes
to
uh your education that you took out from
the government right right well and
i why i wanna but they used to not to
because when i was in school and people
before me
you had a little bit of subsidized debt
and the most of your debt was
unsubsidized it wasn't federally backed
and they changed that years ago because
they realized that that was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah so so they changed it
so so the people who are really bitching
and like oh well i paid off my student
debt already because i went to school 25
like yeah but you paid off unsubsidized
debt a completely different type of debt
of what we're talking about here but
also the people that are saying like oh
you know it's the same people that are
like in my generation we did this well
also in your generation the cost of
living to what you were getting paid and
earned was much different right you
could have a family and raise children
on one person's salary
instead of now having one one of the
parents having to work two to three jobs
and that's what jesus christ in the 60s
70s and 80s you could go to college and
pay for college by having a job at the
same time right you cannot do that now
yeah there's like i i think about my i
mean unless you go get a million dollar
loan from your dad right mitt romney you
know i mean
just go to your parents anyone can do
that yeah yeah yeah and all parents have
a million dollars
right
but i mean like you know i i think back
to my my mom and her siblings and my
grandparents right and
one you know he worked at a telephone
company he was he worked in
communications and like that is what he
did and he was able to
raise a family and support them
on one person's salary and then when my
mom and her siblings went to school they
were able to afford it because it wasn't
crazy
the price of tuition or the price of of
higher education was not like this crazy
huge gap that had uh that had jumped
over
um the rate of inflation and that's what
we see now which is like this insane
concept that higher education despite
having the same
resources and the same output of the
degree that you get higher education
becomes get more and more and more
expensive and it it
it jumps from where the rate of
inflation is so it's like
anyone who says oh well in my day or you
should be able to push yourself over
your bootstraps or you should be able to
you know uh to pay off this loan it's
like yeah look look look
if the if the wages went up
and the expenses went down and these
other things played the same way that
they did before
you're saying joe biden are you saying
joe biden needs an income button and an
inflation button next to it sounds like
it like
in terms of all these buttons i mean
like this desk really i bet is like a
control center of life gas go down gas
go up inflation go up and place you go
down right right you can't get all these
knobs just right just handling these but
at the same time it's also like people
who are like oh it's all or nothing
right we talked about yesterday these
like busters nina turner i want to call
her out my name nina turner [ __ ] her
again you can't you can't have all or
nothing because a hundred percent of
nothing
is [ __ ] nothing no turner and and and
again and people might knock me for for
saying bad [ __ ] about her but i don't
give a [ __ ] she can i really honestly
i'll send the link to nina turner right
now someone wants to shoot the show i
mean it's just it's one of those things
like nina turner is definitely a it's
all or nothing banger bus like it's got
to be one or the other it is one or zero
yes or no it's not binary right we live
right
could we
could we resolve and and
clear the books for all of these student
debts yeah sure i mean like well i don't
i don't know i i but when i said this in
the first 30 minutes i think
i think that's the main debate to have
here right is
can the president actually do this right
and we won't know when oh yeah yeah
until a president does this right but
that's the thing i think what is so
important about what joe biden did
yesterday is he is testing the waters
rather the president really actually has
this power but he did it in a way to
make sure if he does have this power
that this plan is most effective for the
american people not for colleges not for
universities not for the [ __ ] banks
not for the federal [ __ ] government
he had one set of people in mind the
people who actually [ __ ] are saddled
with these loans
and i think that is most important for
people especially all the [ __ ] out
there like oh this is unfair i paid mine
or or my daddy paid mine so i didn't i
don't get my ten thousand dollar check
no one's getting ten thousand dollar
checks yeah no one is no one is getting
a check to pay off it is saying right
you do not have to pay this amount
anymore which again is very different
from getting like a stimulus check which
really is it is a revealing aspect when
people are talking about this like oh
it's going to increase inflation
we are not adding money
like we are not injecting uh
new money into
into the economy we're not giving people
checks to pay off because then at that
point you'd be like well here's a ten
thousand dollar check
and how do you know that the ten
thousand dollar check is going to be
applied to education right
it's not so the best tactic is to remove
those costs from the actual balance
sheet of you as a student or a former
student that has loans under a
government
agreement
right and so
this is one of those things we hear with
toit it's like oh it's got to be this or
it's got to be that it's like look we
are making
small improvements we are trying to fix
a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] and i think
that's where a lot of people get really
like uh upset about right i agree
should there be any student debt no
education should be free just like
healthcare just like other services that
we have in this country they should be
free because we are tax paying citizens
we should be a lot of those things it
should be we should be giving those
things well we do get free education up
till you know you're a senior in high
school and i think me you and brett
talked about this yesterday is is
there needs to be movement right there
needs to be movement towards community
colleges being a a a piece of public
education that actually someone can go
and get one one two year degree
um to enter into a workforce i think
that's appropriate or or a trade score
two years right or a trade school right
like i've you know i've got friends who
are electricians they didn't go to
college and you know
they were making
six figures right yeah a lot of a lot of
those trades make way more money than
even in a college degree and it's it's
one of those things i'm like um i kind
of wonder i think back i'm like
if i had known that if i was able to
earn that type of income earlier on in
my career or earlier on in my life
post high school would i have done that
i don't know right like i went to school
for something and i do something
completely different right now so you
know it i don't know what that could
have done for me but it's it's that's a
good point that's a good point about
this program because this is one of the
other [ __ ] naysayer things
is oh tuition is going to go up well
then you weren't listening yesterday it
doesn't matter how much tuition goes up
it doesn't matter because now the
repayment of that tuition on subsidized
loans
is twofold
the discretionary the discretionary
income of the minimum payment got cut to
half the five percent with this program
yeah that's bad that's right
that's a big [ __ ] deal which i
actually think the president has that
power he definitely has that power which
that i don't i think of all the things
that will actually stand more than any
of it as far as the court because the
president has that power
now the other thing that is so important
with this which is going to make
universities in college do their [ __ ]
job which is to give people education
for job placement and a career in the
economy
is that
it the the the uh the cap on years is
either 10 or 20 20 in most cases right
so the college now has to think not
about tuition but about okay we're gonna
get
five percent minimum
of someone's discretionary income yeah
and we're only going to get it for 20
[ __ ] years so we have to do a
damn good job a damn good job of making
sure our students
get the highest paying [ __ ] jobs out
there right so that you know that we get
the highest amount of that five percent
discretionary spending in a minimum a
minimum amount for 20 years how in the
[ __ ] don't these people understand that
that is
tuition could be a gazillion dollars
gabe it doesn't matter what it is if you
if you are capped at 20 years
and your minimum that you have to pay is
five percent of your discretionary
spending well [ __ ] what
right i mean it doesn't matter what it
is
people want to make the argument that
like oh raising tuition will be the
result of this because no longer can you
get 10 percent or it's you know it's you
can keep refinance or whatever it is
then great let's have that conversation
right right exactly that's a good debate
to have that is a good conversation
about a broken higher education system
that relies on gouging people for money
right and not changing the end result
which is you have this piece of paper
with your diploma i get that it's you
know it's tangible however
is my education 10 years ago 20 years
ago any different with some
some slight changes to like new things
that were discovered
any different from what would be
taught and learned uh and earned as a
degree today
probably not right and you're talking
about the knowledge between your actions
right exactly i'm saying like if someone
were to go to an ivy league school i
mean like you know we'll use that as an
example which is probably i don't know
like a 80 to 100k in terms of what
degree or even if you were to go to
another private institution like
let's say it started at 30k and within a
10-year range they bumped it up 8 10k
it now comes into question a much larger
conversation which i agree we should
definitely have which is does the rate
of increasing
tuition
does that ju is that justified
over time right or are you saying oh
well it's for this and this and that
right like are there other changes that
justifies probably not at the end of the
day you've got private donors who donate
to a building the tuition pays for part
of it but you have higher paying donors
that will put their [ __ ] name on the
building
to do that well they commercialized
everything in these guys yeah i mean i
mean here's the thing is up until a few
years ago even the [ __ ] athletes who
were receiving full-ride scholarships
couldn't even get to school to pay for a
hot dog because it was against the rules
well that's even i mean that's even
another discussion right but but that's
what i'm trying to say is that is that
the schools the schools and the
universities are part of the biggest
issue um and it's really the
indoctrination of america that you can't
participate in the economy without
higher education which i believe to some
degree but that doesn't mean that
college and universities have a monopoly
on what that higher education is i think
that is the [ __ ] that we have
there's community colleges there's tech
schools
a lot of people can get a really good
paying job with a two-year degree the
same [ __ ] job that they can get with
a really expensive four-year degree i
think that's been the indoctrination of
the american people right and so many
people were [ __ ] tricked into [ __ ]
going and getting this debt because they
thought they would get him ahead and and
and and yes the federal government was
part of that and the the society was
part of that i'm not saying that someone
shouldn't have a four-year degree there
are certain things that you should have
advanced degrees for but there are other
things that people can can afford to
have a two-year degree and do a job and
make a decent living and live the
quote-unquote american dream without
having to sit around their house eating
[ __ ] like you said oatmeal and
[ __ ]
peanut butter because they're they're
terrified to
to forgo and forbear these loans because
the interest that's another thing in
this program right the interest stacks
up on it yeah
because here cascasmo says no tuition
until job fruition but i think that's
what this plan starts to start to
implement right it starts to walk to
that direction where the universities
and the colleges are now going to have
to take responsibility for this debt
because for so long even with pell
grants we were talking about pell grants
yesterday and you receive pell grants
pell grants aren't [ __ ] grants how
how convenient for the government to go
oh yeah we'll grant you a loan that you
have to pay back the rest of your life
we'll do that right
and that's the thing right
i saw somebody because because i i was a
recipient of pell grants but here's the
thing like pell grants are
mostly free however right things happen
when they say oh actually you do have to
pay that's right i saw a comment
yesterday when we were live they're like
oh you don't have to pay bill pell grant
so it's actually right you do and i
experience that because your status
changes let's say your parents make uh
you know let's say one of your parents
changes the household income
after the fact of when you receive this
pell grant right and that status changes
the household income so they go well
you're no longer qualified so that means
you have to pay it back the same thing
is said if you change your status like
people who drop out they have to pay
that back because they did not complete
the contractual agreement of the grant
they would use this money for the grant
there are other things that go into
place that change a status that would
say
oh like uh there was another thing where
you can actually be
allotted more money by the government
because certain people might
might not be checking things when you're
going through the fafsa kind of program
they go okay great they're great and
it's actually
uh over what the tuition amount is and
they go okay well actually now we decide
which things you owe us back we won't
just like oh we're going to block out
this one they go you might a little bit
of this one you might a little that one
so in the end you actually can owe money
back that you have to pay and the
interest rates are what [ __ ] you over so
much and that was one of the things that
i had to deal with the first couple
years after leaving school which was
like [ __ ] like there there is a i think
a six month period where you don't have
to pay right it's like the trends the
transition period of you having to
determine okay my job where i'm living
am i situated enough where i can now say
okay i can pay these loans back but at
the same time you also have to look at
and say well [ __ ] which one am i paying
back first like you know you
the the the way that you're
you should do it is you should be paying
back the higher interest rates but when
you're coming out of school
uh right now to get as a 22 year old 21
year old whatever you might be you might
be like well [ __ ] i don't know which one
i'm gonna pay off the one that's the
lowest amount and get it off but you're
like actually you should be paying off
the higher interest rate and that's
something that people aren't educated on
oh you mean the college and the
universities don't explain to you that
exactly right these are things where
it's like oh you should learn you should
learn this out of the gate and that's
the unfortunate thing was like there
isn't the financial education especially
as an 18 year old when you're signing
this agreement from a private
institution let's say it's a bank like
chase or something and you agree i'm
going to take out forty thousand dollars
for whatever length of time during
school over a couple years or whatever
you have to now say okay great but they
don't tell you
you know when you should which you
should pay back all of these things they
just say you agreed to it 18 year olds
great your name's on it
and when you finish school you have to
pay it back
but there's no kind of explanation or no
like tldr to break it down to be like
here are the bullet points you should
pay back this one first you should try
to refinance this one you should try to
maybe take another loan to pay this one
off right like there are so many things
that go into place that nobody's
educated on and so people end up like
well [ __ ] i can't pay this loan back
then i and and the other thing too
is the [ __ ] up thing about higher
education loans is how they do not die
with the person if they die they then
get transferred onto the next of kin
they don't work the same way as loans do
well and and that well if fake gabe has
a comment here and i want to i want to i
want to educate fake gabe here for a
second because gabe's all if it gabe i
fake gabe i'm glad you're at facebook
you come here every single day yeah
every day you're here fake game and i
appreciate you being here i mean he's
here he's playing the video you are a
dumb son of a [ __ ] on this comment you
you i mean you just gave me a target to
aim for why are we facing higher
interest rates democrats stifling the
modern economies likely up gabe
fake gabe the
the interest rates for um
subsidized loans have nothing to do with
the fed
dummy nothing and if you knew anything
and if you did just a hint just a little
hint
of a little bit of research you would
know that the federal government
actually sets that interest rate and it
is a fixed interest rate across the
board it is the same [ __ ] yeah
it doesn't matter who you are what you
are it's they set the interest rate so
so take take your head okay i know it's
lodged up there really far you got it to
sniff the trump turd i know you got it
lodged up there really far but fake gabe
i appreciate you being here every day
and eventually eventually you watch the
tony michaels podcast long enough we'll
work your head out of your ass and we'll
pluck it out of there for you and you
can wash it off and you can join the
rest of us in reality so again
there's a lot of components here and i i
um someone told me this morning someone
i personally know actually it may have
been yesterday when i talked to him on
the phone about this um they said that
he should have did something with the
industry speaking of the interest rate
that fixed interest rate that the
federal government charges which the
federal government makes a shitload of
money i mean they're [ __ ] rolling in
the dough with that interest rate
because it's something stupid
stupid on on higher education and it's
compounding even when you're forbearing
that [ __ ] compounds so here's
the thing here's the thing
is that with that interest rate that
interest rate really isn't going to
matter either because they did part of
that program did do that but the thing
is
is that with the 5 discretionary income
minimum payment and the 10 or 20 years
whichever you
whichever you qualify for for that cap
that is going to set this in motion
where the federal government almost has
to decide whether they're even going to
charge interest or not at this point so
i understand that this plan is not the
the most comprehensive plan that
everyone would want but a comprehensive
plan is gonna have to come from us the
people the government so we are gonna
have to go vote for people who will set
the policy that we're talking about but
we can't elect [ __ ] boneheads like
lauren bobert and marjorie taylor
swattery taylor green i think that's
what i'm going to call now swattery
taylor green i'm just saying yeah was
she swatted again is this a thing
i read that she got legitimately
allegedly she was swatted she was at
least swatted more than once i don't
know
if it was done
if it was like look sweet was one of
them real and one of them
i just want to make clear swatting
is terrible you should not swat anyone
right did someone legitimately swat her
or was this done by the pipe bomber i
don't know
i don't know
well for anyone who doesn't know
swatting
is very a very malicious activity where
someone claims that someone's committing
crimes inside of a home
and
the type of crimes that a swat team
would show up and bust down the door
um which uh frankly uh it should be a
very high felony and the other thing too
is like
you know not everyone makes it out alive
when someone is swatted especially if
you're in a certain neighborhood right
demographic perspective
right like those are things and i think
there's i'm trying to remember there's a
uh there is a netflix series
yes
i've watched that and one and i think
the first one yeah and the first one is
swat and it's it's it all started like
gamers trying to distract
their um the people that they were
competing against so they could win
whatever the competition was right and
then it became a thing of like swatting
is now like how many how many like
ticks on the board can i get double
things horrible dude do not do not swap
margarita
a swattery taylor green as funny as it
is don't do that um but here
back to back to the student loan then
we'll get to the shitless right now
because i gotta i've got a video of matt
getz and i'm gonna show you gabe i've
been dying to show you this video this
morning this thing oh my god this thing
is going to be great in democratic ads
they should be making ads right now
about this [ __ ]
he was on i think he was on trader tv
network i don't know if it was steve
bannon i probably he wasn't on his fire
brand tv no no it's not him he's do he's
doing he's doing a [ __ ] interview a
fascist oh okay and i called him i
called him the what did i say i said the
the four-headed florida fascist that's
what i call them four-headed florida
fascists that works out pretty good
that's a pretty good nickname i mean i
already call him matt gatz which is
right not how he says his name yeah yeah
the four-headed florida fascist that's
perfect but i'm going to show you this
video but one one other thing i want to
touch on on this student loan before we
get to the shitless
roundup uh for the for the naysayers
yeah for the naysayers out there because
i think the most important um uh aspect
of this
is that
the majority of folks and i touched on
it in the first block but i want to talk
to you about it for a second because um
rural areas really
are going to see a lot of trump
supporters are going to receive these
benefits a lot of them because there's a
lot of people in rural areas who went to
college who did not finish or went to
college and have low paying jobs even
though they have college degrees and a
lot of rural areas if people don't
understand this even if you have a
college dream you have a good job and a
real pain in a rural area a lot of times
they're like i don't know 60 80 90 000.
most of those jobs you do not make over
you do not make 125 000 right even
holding a college degree and getting a
degree in your field that you're working
in
it's it's it's not it's not abnormal in
a rural area for that to be the case so
a lot of rural folks who live in rural
areas who have college degrees who have
jobs but they're not making over 125 000
are going to benefit from this i
actually don't think that joe biden did
some kind of jedi mind trick and he's
trying to trick trump supporters into
supporting this but at the end of the
day i actually think joe biden's like
they're americans too right right
they're americans too and really if we
lift their boat maybe maybe they won't
be such [ __ ] right i mean i said yes
a rising tide will lift all boats this
is one of those things where also
this is something that no other
republican no other former president can
say that they put into place right they
this is the president who put forward a
specific
objective to say he would eliminate 10
to 20k depending on what type of loan
you have
for you if you make under 125 000
that is something that some like a
republican can't be like oh yeah yeah we
that was in the jobs act or that was in
this thing that was in that right
actually they did the opposite with the
tax cuts for the rich right right it's
basically the exact economic opposite
right and that's what a lot of people
don't talk about is like how you know it
changes after 2021 and how it actually
increases and the rich get richer and
the middle class that would like got
this tax cut didn't really get the tax
cut in the long run well well they they
got just enough of that first couple
years to right
well that's the thing right and so and
so this is one of those things where
it's like you objectively cannot say to
anyone
once these things go into effect and
start having a positive impact on
people's lives and that they're saving
money that they can
allocate elsewhere car house children
whatever
you cannot say as a republican oh yeah
this was in this thing no this is a
specific thing that president biden did
that will have a positive impact on well
on a majority of americans not only the
people that are the the recipients of
those loans and forgiven loans but also
the people that are in the community
because this is now money that will then
be allocated elsewhere right
and so this isn't and again this isn't
injecting new money and this is money
that they already earned
that we're saying hey look we cut this
cost this is like saying i'm for
anything else it's like oh look we cut
your car payments down right
or gas is going down so you don't have
to pay as much per gallon
you're going to use the same amount of
gallons right the money that you already
have you can now use for other things
that you need that are essential in your
life so maybe maybe before we go to the
[ __ ] list round up here maybe the
president now should now that he's
giving all this money to all these folks
and they're going to be so excited about
it maybe what he should do is turn that
gasoline button back up
turn now oh yeah really really stick the
screws to the american people you know
raise those gas fires really get it
going yeah i mean [ __ ] why not why not
he wants to help out corporations
college and universities can suck it for
right now corporations baby that's where
it's at uh we got to get to the [ __ ] i
want to show you this matt dance video
so everyone we're going to go to the
shitless round but let's surf the tweety
tweets and trendy trends let's start the
countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome to the shitless roundup
of we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends gabe i got a great
video i want to show you i'm excited i'm
excited matt getz
oh my god this [ __ ] guy what did he
say this oh my well um
he's he's just doing the quiet part out
loud again right uh oh oh
i thought it was steve bannon but it's
not it's charlie kirk's trader tv
they're on the same network right right
yeah they
charlie kirk and steve bannon are on the
same trade or network right and that am
i right in that i think that's correct
uh i know i don't know sorry charlie
kirk and steve bannon is that what we
said yeah they're on yeah trader okay
that's this real america the real
america's voice right right this thin
void americanism
we're patriots we want to tear down the
democracy we want a fascist state well
listen to what the the forehead that
florida fascist has to say about how he
wants to turn
our government's [ __ ] hours
into a goddamn fascist court listen i
have a vision that is specific for the
republican control of the house and
divide okay first off
any kind of vision that comes out of
this noggin look at this guy
does he like have a [ __ ] air pump for
his head
i think you know i think he you can
i mean i got a big head and imagine my
imagine tony do you remember that the
reebok air pumps
yeah mm-hmm right so maybe yeah i had
the little basketball yeah yeah so maybe
i have actually a pair in my closet over
here okay uh
are they vintage are they are they like
replicas uh they're not the original oh
they're they're but they're i mean
they're the same they're the same you
know the same model i had a set of pumps
when i was a kid i think we only had
them one year but yeah yeah so maybe the
tongue like the tongue on the shoe right
of the reebok air pumps like
and they said
right
soon soon his head is gonna like
look like this weird [ __ ]
it's like vase shape kind of thing going
on i mean this guy's got like an eight
head i make fun of it because it's a
forehead but it's like an eight jesus is
he in a hotel why is he hotel i don't i
don't know where this is at i don't know
where he's he's uh he's
he's traitoring from i'm not really sure
but he's got ideas gabe he's got a dream
a vision that's got that that's good for
him that's actually kind of scary that
this guy is thinking of sitting around
thinking about stuff but let's listen
let's hear what his vision is for this
fascist state that he so desires
government we have to convert every
single committee to an oversight
committee and once we commit to that
paradigm then you could say okay you
don't have to create like a select
committee oh my god okay first off first
off
congress's main
congress does a couple different things
and the house of representatives they
they allocate funds right that is that's
one of their jobs is to appropriate
okay they also write legislation which
appropriates funds in most cases
but one of the committee's jobs almost
any committee there is is oversight what
the [ __ ] does he think committees are
for
probably if i if i had to guess based on
matt gates history he believes that
committees
are for the moments when you can look up
photos of naked women that he may or may
not have slept with and share them with
other people
that's why he has no clue that
committees
generally
are are are working bills that
appropriate funds and are doing
oversight of other government agencies
did you know he he really missed the
checks and balances part of that didn't
he did you know that when he first
entered the uh
as a u.s representative
paul ryan had to set him aside
and talk to him about how his behavior
was juvenile
and it wasn't professional
do you you mean paul ryan the guy that
took the photo of him in the gym yeah
just work yeah doing some bicep curls
that guy had to explain to this guy
what what immaturity is and what
maturity is that's yeah amazing yeah
that's amazing by the way amazing so
matt matt gets the forehead florida
fascist here
he has no clue i guess i don't know or
maybe he's just gaslighting the [ __ ]
viewers of this trader news network and
maybe charlie kirk doesn't know this and
he's schooling him on what congress what
congress's responsibilities are you
would think again as a member of
congress for as many times as he's
unfortunately been a member of congress
wouldn't understand that he is a
congressperson is supposed to be the
check and balance and oversight of the
uh what's that other branch executive is
that what it is yeah there's a few
branches a few branches what a [ __ ]
bonehead okay let's hear how he wants to
do oversight though this is where it
gets really [ __ ] weird it gets really
scary and he starts to say some [ __ ]
that really sounds like 1930s 1940s
germany
you just assign you know the hunter-byte
matter to foreign affairs you assign
vaccine injuries to the health care
committees you assign breaking up big
tech to the commerce committee you
assign getting uh the woke-ism out of
our military to the armed services
committee and
okay um
so here we have here we have the fascist
forehead from florida being the
absolute fascist he can possibly be on
this trader news network so he literally
is saying he didn't know that congress
has oversight that that committees have
oversight ability i guess yeah but now
now he doesn't understand that you can't
what you can't do inside of a of an
official hearing like a committee
is have a committee based on entire sets
of lies like that's not gonna that's not
gonna work very well because you
actually have to inside this committee
when you're doing oversight you have to
bring those things called um what the
hell are those things called that um
they starts with an f and ends and not
alternative but what's the facts oh
right [ __ ] idiot this [ __ ] idiot
you have to bring some facts
what is wokism in the military by the
way what the [ __ ] is that
they're they believe locism in the
military is the
when they're like hey look we will now
have uh
anyone regardless of what gender they
identify with in the military oh you
mean bigotry you mean they're yeah well
that's what they want they're like they
they're like you know the fact that we
you know put out a video that was like
hey we accept everyone if you have the
[ __ ] guts to serve in the military
and do your time because that's what it
takes right
then we we we welcome you we will not we
will not push you away despite what
trump and republicans want to do
you know they're like oh well if you're
not a man in the military then it's
[ __ ] weak dude it's [ __ ] weak
that's what republicans believe and that
is what they're like oh they're all woke
now
because it's not just a bunch of men
acting like dicks right that's
that's [ __ ] they're the stuff okay
these are the same [ __ ] they're like
oh it's unfair that people are getting
their debt paid off even though i'm one
of them i'm going to take the general
also any any moment of any anything that
that's right like any racism that is
brought forward because a a committee or
a panel is like oh look we investigated
this matter turns out this guy was a
[ __ ] bigot
and was doing hate crimes against people
and they're like well that's what we
want the military like that is what
they're advocating for and anyone who
brings or sheds light on those things
that say hey we got a big [ __ ]
problem in the military here in this
group whether it's the air force the
army or the navy or whatever it might be
and we need to reprimand this person
and remove them right like just like you
would do a cancerous cell we need to
remove them
they go no no no that's woke that's woke
it's like no wonder
no wonder they get so upset when you're
like hey look we found out there's
[ __ ] a gang ring
within the the the police department and
it's we're finding that these people are
being um you mean actual corruption
actual facts yeah exactly like here at
like la la sheriff's department we got
[ __ ] gangs in there
right it's one of those things with like
oh no
police are doing their job they're doing
a good job right it's like despite the
fact that they're
you know unfairly treating people of
color or you know taking bribes or being
corrupt in other ways and anytime you
want to bring those things up you want
to address a problem and say hey we
could be better we could be doing a
better job
of enforcing the law and helping the
community
but they go
well it was it was fine how it was but i
think i think it's much more simple than
that to this idiot and here's we we
talked to adam absolutely yesterday
about darth vader junior and liz cheney
yeah and the difference in republicans
nowadays
are few of them i guess yeah
it used to be
that
these [ __ ] republicans they wanted
power and oversight
like for instance public education we've
been talking about this student loan
thing
like you want republicans in charge of
student loans well [ __ ] they're going to
get rid of the entire department of
education like they want to abolish it i
think this [ __ ] matt has even
said as much in tweet as much that he
wants to abolish the department of
education well they all want to irs
right education right they don't they
they don't want oversight well despite
him saying he wants well they want
oversight on people who aren't them
that's what they want well they don't
want regulation right well but well but
i think it goes beyond that because that
is a liz cheney type republican where
she uses conservatism this the the thin
veil the fascism right right matt gatz
is not using conservatism he's like i'm
an america first nazi and we want to
make sure that we get all the woke
people out of our country and send them
to concentration camps sounds like 1930s
1940s germany to me yeah but here's the
thing
is that
really like even if you just take the
department of education thing
some people years ago would have said
well we want to abolish the department
of education so we can give big school
contracts to our rich buddies that is
not what matt matt gads is not like i
want to abolish the department of
education to make sure my rich donors
get right get school contracts he's like
i want to abolish the department
education so we can walk these people to
concentration camps and get rid of the
people that don't like me because i'm
gonna go to prison because i'm a [ __ ]
pedophile if if i don't get rid of all
these woke people these woke people who
don't like pedophiles is a bunch of
[ __ ] he really is he really is a
[ __ ] idiot the other thing i mean you
got to remember that these republicans
are the ones who you know even people
like christian walker last year were
talking about education camps right and
they were talking about people being
taken education camps these liberals
these [ __ ] blue-haired left coast
liberals trying to indoctrinate the
children
which i find very odd
when you have people like ron desantis
who wants to send teachers
to education camps it's like can we one
if you're gonna if you're good gabe
they colored their hair blue god damn it
well the only thing what to say about
this is look if you're trying to be a
nazi maybe use different language than
camps right
like maybe try and find a new way to
rebrand yourself even though nazis
are not creative they will repeat the
same [ __ ] over and over again we see it
over and over and over and they will not
last because democracy will defeat
fascism
but right now we have these people like
ron desantis who wants to be president
you know he's saying oh we gotta send
them to education camps we got to make
them despite the fact that they were
educated and that they went to school to
get a degree that they're still paying
off and that this this uh student debt
loan forgiveness will definitely help
them
you have people like ron desantis who
wants to say no no no
if you don't believe what i believe
then off to the camps
that's right and then well hopefully i
can re-indoctrinate you
into believing what i believe whatever
you don't then you're gone one of our
great moderators here minus ramen says
keep them poor keep them stupid keep
them ill keep them angry it's the gop
way you're exactly right spot on robin
that's that's their goal here and and
again uh it's a big dumpster fire
speaking of big dumpster fires this is
uh must be breaking news jewish gender
resistor says a lo a live look at red
states as republicans continue to [ __ ]
us over let me pull this video up this
is uh breaking news i think um let's
watch this video here i want to pull
i got to pull down the banner so you can
see you can see the greatest part about
this um here we go if you look down here
in the corner
you see the
republicans really
i got i got to turn the sound off
because they're gonna they're gonna oh
my god they're gonna ding you for that
one i'm gonna ding us just imagine it's
celine dion
and you know jack and rose are at the
front of the titanic or this oil tanker
breaking news breaking
news a live look
at republicans
[ __ ] over people in red states as the
red state burns and what what a great i
mean you know i we we bring you the
heartbreaking news here the hard yeah
i mean let me tell you we are
for two hours we go pretty hard we hump
and help and hump but if it goes over
four hours then we do need to call it
that is true you know we streamed for
three and a half hours yesterday did you
know that i didn't i haven't streamed
from over three hours yeah i know it was
like three and a half yeah it's like
three and a half hours it's gonna prove
that um i think to our audience that we
can do three hours i'm kind of scared of
that but i think that's i think that's
what's going to happen i have something
delicious here to show you um gabe it's
patriot takes pose to this i said it was
delicious um it said 20 points usa
influencer i really don't even know what
the hell that means i mean i know it's i
know it's charlie kirk's turning point
usa yeah what does that mean
turning point usa influence is there is
there like a turning point usa
like you know how these people have like
oh there's the elderly house and there's
like the
there's this house and that house
they're all like the tick tock houses
you know right stuff like that
do you think charlie kirk has one i i
have no idea i don't know what exactly
that means but patriot takes is on top
of this so he must know what turning
point usa influencer means but this this
influencer i don't know her name i don't
really give a [ __ ] to know her name um i
don't know she looks like every other
conservative that i've seen online she
attacks trump over the cobot vaccine the
reason why i think this is so important
is because it's the same reason why i
found uh john bolton attacking trump so
important is because they're eating the
[ __ ] sandwich is eating the [ __ ]
sandwich as i say and this is where we
can draw wedges like we can really drive
wedges into these [ __ ]
um politicizing this stuff
but let's listen to this wrangled up
cowboy hat and see what it has to say
i'm sure it's all true all of it i'm
sure 100 people is now saying that the
trump admin pressured the fda to
authorize unproven treatments for the
rona and the first orona jabby jabs on
an accelerated timeline
what what did she say
jabby jabs jabby jet the ronin well
because they love calling it the [ __ ]
fauciouchi and they love conan at the
jab and oh well i'm not against
nicknames i think they're fun yeah but
they think that the nickname cool i
think it's because they're one
attempting to
try to get around any sort of like
content moderation
you notice here she's getting the kova
19 covered up with like a syringe so she
thinks if she puts a picture of kobe 19
on here that she's gonna get banned or
some [ __ ] it's not it's honey it's not
what you're showing it's what it's the
dumb [ __ ] you're saying yeah i'm rather
banning you let's let's continue to hear
what she doesn't really have any
thoughts i guess or real ones i'm not
really sure what's going on but let's
listen we have everybody on the right
wing saying oh well now they're trying
to blame trump they're trying to blame
trump but trump out of his own mouth has
said that he is the father of it and
that he is very very proud of it he's
taking full responsibility for it
whether he has bad advisors or not i
don't know but did you know that since
2017 he has been pushing for quicker fda
approval of pharmaceutical drugs
university of america
okay i'm i'm not done with that here's
the point here's the point that i was
trying to make with this and why it's so
delicious is because they're turning on
each other this is fantastic and how
they didn't see this coming i have no
idea how didn't you not see this coming
and the reason why is because trump does
this on everything
everything he tries to both sides of the
fence like of course i'm responsible i'm
the king i invented the vaccines is what
it basically says like i was in the oval
office bathroom on the sink and bending
these back these vaccines right there
i was eating
the actual pharmaceutical ingredients on
paper and i was [ __ ] out fda
approved
pharmaceuticals is this is that part of
the documents that was in the 15 boxes
probably i'm just you know just trying
to figure that out
queen that that was the other papers you
can see you saw me maggie haberman and
and others and then underneath it was
actually you know hydrochloroquine and
ram dem severe and all these things
gotcha gotcha well i want to go to the
the trendy trends now yeah because
there's a lot of stuff uh trending i
don't know if you've seen joel olsteen
is trending of course there's a lot of
reasons why this guy could trend but the
one reason why he's training on twitter
today is the celebrity pastor joel
olsteen
began repayment of his mega churches
4.4 million dollars in pp
ppp loan now this is important and the
reason why this is important today is
because a lot of people are having this
discussion about how it's [ __ ] unfair
for
um people to receive student loan debt
when people like this [ __ ]
received
4.4 million dollars in a ppp loan now
because of the pushback on that i guess
the lakewood church which is the name of
the
of the of the dumpster fire mega church
that this guy that this this [ __ ]
money laundering scheme that this guy
runs um is started to pay back the the
paycheck protection program which is the
ppp loan that he took for the kova kova
19 relief
um
but i guess because people had brought
this up
because of the 10 000 of the student
loan debt relief they pointed out that
hey [ __ ] you're saying it's
unfair that an average american who does
the supposed right thing goes to college
gets a degree has a job is having
struggling even with that job having a
degree is struggling to repay their
loans doesn't deserve a little bit of
relief but here this [ __ ] runs a
goddamn money laundering machine a
church of all things who is tax exempt
[ __ ] him all churches should basically
be yeah i mean like let's the 4.4
million is
nothing no no no that is nothing
compared to the three billion
catholic church received from ppp loans
and and the the most important part here
is that the catholic church already had
10 billion dollars on hand in short-term
liquid uh are you telling me churches
are sitting on cash do you remember when
this [ __ ] a few years ago um
they found that he oh when he closed the
doors
well that too but no they they they
reported a bunch of money stolen and
then yeah
well no you jump seven years ahead and
then someone finds a bunch of oh that's
what it was right in the wall behind the
toilet or something yeah yeah real sus
right why was the money stolen and
hidden inside the church seems like a
bit of a rainy day fund in case
something goes wrong
but yeah again you i i look i was raised
catholic i went to catholic grade school
indoctrinated
with religion that way okay we're going
to talk about indoctrination like i have
spent years trying to forget
prayers and things that happened so when
i go to church for a friend's wedding or
something and they start [ __ ] they
say one one [ __ ] hymn or one
uh one reading like that [ __ ] comes back
within a flash and i don't even know
that i'm doing it subconsciously but i'm
get you know i'm saying the prayer with
it but if you were to ask me what's the
prayer right now i could be like uh
maybe i could give you the first three
words
but this is one of those things where
you know i grew up in a catholic
household in catholic grade school and
did all of that and
you look at
the catholic just catholicism right you
got the vatican its own [ __ ] country
it's got its own [ __ ] private bank
they have billions which are willing
they are willing to
to uh relocate uh priests who have been
uh caught you know [ __ ] playing with
kids
being pedophiles you've got the catholic
church who is willing to pay the legal
expenses to cover this up and give hush
money
but when it came to ppp loans they were
like oh yeah yeah we need money we need
money because we have to help support
the paychecks for those around us like
[ __ ] no you guys have the resources to
pay the paychecks and cover the time
period between
when the pandemic started and you know
this time now but you guys will give
that get that money forgiven you know
because you
you paid it out right well here's yours
[ __ ] which is [ __ ] well yeah but
here's the list um we i think we looked
at this yesterday when we were waiting
for the president to have his press
conference this graphic here it says
republican members of congress whose ppp
loans were forgiven not that they got
the money it was forgiven matt gatz at
the very top who was saying that the um
you know oh it's unfair
right 476
000
that that pedophile got i mean that
congressman got excuse excuse my uh
excuse my 40 and slipped there um
swattery taylor green 180 000
greg pence
the former vice president's
brother 79 000
and there and the list goes on and on
and on here and i'm sure every one of
these [ __ ] if you wouldn't ask
them how do you feel about average
americans who are struggling to pay back
their loans get ten thousand dollars to
help in that effort [ __ ] them [ __ ] damn
them lazy bastards they don't deserve
any kind of government money no safety
net no handout these people are lazy
they're eating cheetos on the couch they
want to work a day in their life give me
a [ __ ] break okay let me show you an
example of this
of one of the people on the list here
swattery taylor green yeah i think it
was like actually like a hundred and
eighty three thousand dollars yeah
there's also if you look up the story
behind this by the way which is like how
much money she took and how much money
she lost in the ppp loan that she that
her business took better for her
business yeah her business took i think
400 and
oh no sorry up to 300 350 and then like
you also look at like how much money was
then loaned out to her campaign during
the time it's almost us it's all right
right it's she is suspicious i'm gonna
point out in this video what else is
suspicious here but um
she's obviously on on another trader
news network here newsmax giving an
interview about biden's announcement
plan to forgive three billion dollars in
student debt
um
and she she's the expert here i'm sure
on this
that she'd want to besides who you want
to go to is this dumb [ __ ] but let's
listen
to her comment and i'm going to pause it
because i want to point out something
that's suspicious about her background
let's let's let's listen
for our government just to say
hang on i got to turn this up i hate to
turn her up but you can't hear what the
[ __ ] okay let's let's listen but for for
our government just to say you know okay
well your debt is completely forgiven
obviously they have an agenda for that
they need votes in november
okay so i want to point out here
her background do you notice we've
talked about this several times that she
appears in different places like when
she's doing her podcast yeah but lately
she has appeared in what appears to be
like a a wood paneled room
right it's the corner it's the corner of
a room that has
been uh added the bokeh effect on the
camera right that's what i can tell you
right now well so so she's appeared in
this room
and i believe it is actually in georgia
where her business is
um and this is like some people have
said that maybe this is the offices of
that business yeah and it and it's
really [ __ ] it's like cheap ass
paneling right it's like cheap ass wood
paneling that you'd see
you know and again
some people like it you might like that
look from the 1980s or you know
the 70s which is like the linoleum
linoleum walls yeah i mean there's
nothing you know wrong i i i'm not
against tacky but yeah yeah but she
apparently because people were giving
her [ __ ] about this
on the internet she apparently has
decided to blur the paneling so it
doesn't look as much like paneling but
it's obvious she's still sick okay so
sorry quick side note i don't want to be
that guy who's like hey there's a
conspiracy but i just thought of
something
so she gets called out so well
uh i forgot what happened the day before
but the day before something i forget
maybe maybe it was the primaries and and
something was brought up in terms of her
running and then boom she gets she gets
to watch right
yesterday she is
she is target number one of targets one
of the targets but almost like target
number one because she went on to news
maximum place and was like oh nobody
deserves to get these
loans forgiven blah blah blah i mean
just like foot in the mouth all these
republicans are taking the tactic of if
you took a loan you should have to pay
it off
while they're not paying off people
right
exactly so hundreds of thousands she is
like you know first second one on that
list or whatever first one called out
online uh besides others
and then she gets swatted again and
again i don't know if it's real and i
don't know if it was fake but the timing
seems a little bit
odd but you know what she's us i mean
it's us she is so that's what i'm saying
i don't want to be that conspiracy guy
but i am looking at this and i'm like ah
it seems a little weird in the timing of
how these happened right after another
and especially after
she was called out for
taking these loans and people started to
do a little bit more investigation into
how much was forgiven how much she had
taken out how much was then loaned out
today she swatted herself is that what
you're saying
that's what i said i don't know if it
was her or it was the dc pipe bomber or
it was somebody else i thought i know he
was i didn't see that i'm maybe not i
don't know but i like i like the new
nickname though swattery taylor green
yeah i like the name all i will say is
from what i read the person there was a
person who did confess using a
computer-generated voice so they don't
know who it was
uh they admitted oh you're talking about
that person who called in the swap yeah
the first one that i know of they were
like they called in and i guess they
gave the reason there's a video here
gabe it seems like there's a video
somewhere quite possible there could be
a video but i guess it was a computer
generated like distorted voice that was
saying oh the reason i swatted her
was because
uh and when i say i swatted her i'm
saying i swatted as the person who
swatted okay
what right yeah it was not a game or
game sock puppet it was the anyway she's
that
i guess according to police it was a
computer generated voice that
the reason they gave for swatting
margery taylor green was because of the
way in which she was treating the lgbtq
community
oh so then
you mean the first one yeah yeah because
specifically because she will because
last week she had she introduced her
plan with with uh tucker carlson to go
after a gender affirming uh right you
put them in camps right exactly put them
in camps basically so so what you're
saying is posi and maybe i'm hearing
this wrong
what i'm hearing is possibly the first
one's real maybe she thought hey this
news cycle helped me out to cover this
up because of the the it's possible i
don't know one of them one of myself
both of them were but yes i am saying
that it is possible that the second one
could have it seems a little weird
but then again i've seen weirder in life
but it could have been
i don't know i coincidences are very
weird to kind of like justify so it
doesn't seem like that was
legitimate well let's let's listen to
what swattery taylor green has to say
about people who take money and take
loans
with no intention to pay it back and
then get them forgiven let's let's
listen to how scummy that is so the
timing is a pure coincidence there as
well but it's completely unfair and
taxpayers all over the country taxpayers
that never took out a student loan
taxpayers that pay their bills and and
and you know maybe even never went to
college or just hard-working people they
shouldn't have to pay off the great big
student loan debt for for some college
student that piled up massive debt going
to some ivy league school that's not so
i want our not i want our 180 000 back
swattery that's what i want i want it
back i want that money back because well
also it's like you know she's like oh
well people who went to you know ivy
league schools and want to get this for
giving africa like again
it's not being added on the taxpayer
right these are loans that were there
and you know it's essentially like oh
we're going to give you this fake money
and whatever it's forgiven that it's not
it margie taylor green and her her
accusation that one is people trying to
cheat the system they're trying to get
handouts a safety net whatever like
that's not what this is at all
especially when you look at it's ten to
twenty thousand dollars per person that
is not a lot of money and i don't know i
would probably near enough it's not
right or not but that but that
that's what he promised on the campaign
trail and i think that's where they
landed speaking of the swanny
on swattery table she loves the blurred
camera she likes the blur now
apparently and maybe she's trying to
she's trying to hide where she's at
because she's being swatted she's
talking to steve bannon on the trader
news network about this swatting let's
listen to what she has to say on on
steve bannon's trader
uh tv news network and we have to stay
dedicated god damn it the sound again
hang on a second let me turn this up so
you guys can hear it i get i want you
guys to hear that not that i want to
hear that much but let's let's listen
dedicated to getting it done
you've got a pretty big megaphone and
nobody gave you this megaphone in fact
they try to suppress you at every step
of the way because you speak truth to
power are they try is the left because
you lie is that what he means
yeah yeah you speak truth to power you
mean you spread propaganda and lies
about right you [ __ ] why is that what
you mean let's let's continue i've tried
to ascend have you assassinated ma'am
yes they are trying to have me murdered
they are trying to get me killed and
sometimes they're trying to kill me
themselves their own death right
and and they're being arrested for
trying to do that steve last night i was
swatted for a second time a second time
two nights in a row this makes me think
your theory is even more correct
like i always i mean honest honestly i i
i would believe that this is even more
correct at this point that i just look
left is trying to assassinate no one no
one oh my god
she is she is a sitting member of
congress who has protection and has
certain rights and benefits that no
other normal citizen has
this is to see all [ __ ] they said about
kavanaugh though didn't it
yeah yeah yeah same this is one of those
things i mean like that's not the you
know the other thing too is like marcia
the other green you know
just like anyone else who who tried to
profit off of the pandemic by using
essentially insider trading to trade on
what was information that that uh
representatives had same goes here like
these people had a head start in knowing
this program was going to be there and
then tried to benefit themselves and now
that they're you know being held
accountable or being called out for
their hypocrisy and talking about
student loan forgiveness versus pvp loan
forgiveness
you know they want to play victim they
want to say if you took out the loan you
should have to pay back the loan well if
that's the case then you should pay back
the 183 thousand dollars give us our
[ __ ] money back right give us our
[ __ ] money back and also the fact
that these people were like oh yeah
we'll forgive it no interest rates
like we won't we won't charge you on
this
we just trust that you're gonna use the
money for paychecks like you say you
will maybe you do maybe don't
but she's on she's on you know traitor
tv playing the victim of course i was
sodded i was swatted twice and they're
trying to kill me and assassinate me in
the [ __ ] i don't know if that's
necessarily true here
um
so this morning when we were trying to
figure out what the title and the
thumbnail was going to be you asked me
what was trending yeah well um i just
want to i just want to point out that
when i wake up in the morning it's
usually to a text from tony that's like
hey what you put on the title and the
thumbnail
and i go well you've been uploading
because my tip was like what's trending
because he's been up for a few hours oh
well that's not always true hell i'm
just waking up texting you hey man
okay well that's you know especially
after especially after last night i'm
still hanging on from
but this morning i text him this i said
um well [ __ ] commander is trending and
he's like uh what the [ __ ] yeah and
you know what the [ __ ] that's what he
that's what he texts me when i said [ __ ]
commander now i didn't know the reason
why con commander was trending the
reason why it's raining the real reason
why it's trending is that on south
carolina their university their their
mascot is called the game cox i got like
a rooster yeah i had a i had a roommate
who who went to south carolina so every
every saturday let's go gamecocks and he
would like you know go out to the bar
and watch him with his friends
and apparently they're trying to figure
out the name
a big
sir big spur
um that's
that's i feel like it's a tongue twister
yeah and it's that's fine sir big spurs
or big like after a few times you're
like
how much wood could a woodchuck chuck a
woodchuck could chuck wood kind of like
that
but there's some other suggestions
um of the name cluck norris which i kind
of like that one i'm not gonna lie um
chuck norris is a [ __ ] but yeah
that's a good that's a good one cluck
norris uh marco polo which stands i mean
that kind of sex but [ __ ] commander
that's also a good one but um when you
think when you hear [ __ ] commander in
this day and age
especially with some pictures that came
up
linda hears
she said saw [ __ ] commander training
immediately thought of this asset ron
desantis
um we didn't watch this video on the
show which i'm kind of surprised we
didn't this didn't make it on the show
but it was dumb it was dumb it's
horrible it's like his dick caucus
movement
[Music]
and maybe that's why he's the [ __ ]
commander this morning
will he be the alpha cuck commander i
don't know could it be determined it
could be the amp speaking of that
everyone go follow
us on twitter at tonymichaelspod
you don't want to miss the bonehead of
the week poll you can also vote here on
youtube tonight
uh follow follow us on youtube subscribe
on twitter as well and you can vote for
bonnet of the week there's some bone end
of the week uh news gabe
uh speaking of alphabet excited
so we're we're go every week every
friday we do bone in the week in the
second hour i mean we we air it on
sundays on our youtube channel and we
actually download it on the podcast or
upload it for you to download on the
podcast directory so you can download
bonehead of the week in and of itself on
sundays
we have some great news this week the
bone end of the week will actually air
and we haven't worked out a time yet
tomorrow evening it will air on the
midas touch networks youtube channel so
there will be over there
here right and we don't know the time
yet all right we should probably it'll
probably be somewhere in prime time but
we're not sure the time yet and
prime time boys yeah and we may we may
try to change the time over a couple
weeks to figure out what works the best
for folks yeah um but we'll we'll figure
out that time and get it going um also
[ __ ] commander is trending
but also sleaze is trending to number
16.
this is that matt gates
man you could this i feel like i could
just like just uh just like broad stroke
again
tweets could you write about republicans
with the [ __ ] word sleazing oh yeah
jesus this is like unending content
production here at number 16 trending uh
16 sleeves is trending on the surfing
the tweety tweets and trendy trends and
maybe we'll go in that in a second but
also hobby lobby is trending again oh
[ __ ] that place yeah well i i'm not sure
exactly the reason i mean other than
their [ __ ] boxes is the reason why
they're trending but i don't know if
there was something that specifically
happened uh marge is still trending
probably because she uh she's faking
being so i mean being swatted yeah she's
swatting herself swattery taylor green
goldman sachs is trending
sax is trending yeah why what would you
say oh yeah what what what it's because
of warren buffett
oh well he had a tweet that that
basically uh dragged donald trump about
hey you know for someone who says
they're a billionaire they definitely
beg for money a lot of the time
yeah well
i think i think if you click it you'll
probably find the tweet well so i i
actually think it's uh maybe something
different to you it might be an array of
things
um but i think they they did some some
math over at goldman sachs on this
oh student debt yeah student debt and
they found actually
that it does the opposite of what
naysayers are saying
oh would you look at that
it's kind of funny it's kind of funny
yeah i have a i said this yesterday i
said it yesterday and again
doubt me doubt me when i say these
things
and if you want to doubt me sure
speaking of doubt me go get uh we've got
stickers there's coffee cups just go to
store.dtonymichaels.com
or dtonymichaels.com you can find the
link at the top um if you want to doubt
me merch because i'm just saying
yesterday
i said
look this is not this is not going to
have anything to do with inflation as a
matter of fact if it does have to do
with inflation it would be the opposite
right what do i know
what do i know i don't know
i don't know i mean it's crazy the
people that claim to know so much about
the economic factors that go into our
country have no [ __ ] idea
the impacts of something that would
actually be beneficial right they just
think like oh money cut is then also the
same as
money injected right you know and also
the same thing is like oh we're going to
give you 1200 over a year and a half
period and you should be totally fine
while surviving on that that's the other
crazy part is some of these these same
[ __ ] that are saying oh this is
unfair are the same [ __ ] that are
like oh they're still living off their
cover check like what the [ __ ] are you
show me one person who was
living off twelve hundred dollars if
they were lucky enough to receive that
much money
right and that was that was solely
dependent on your your income from the
year previous based on what your your
tax return was so you try to tell me
that the people who got twelve hundred
dollars are one are one
still living off the 1200 because they
definitely
qualified under 75 000
you're telling me that those people
still [ __ ] live off that bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] because that money easily went away
to rent that one because you know brent
didn't change that might have been
frozen at what the rate was but it was
uh you couldn't or what the amount was
but you still had to pay it
nothing else was covered in terms of the
consumers or the citizens you still had
to pay your own expenses speaking of
jerk-offs that always rely on the
government and you know and people to
pay their debts um
you pointed out remember in 2016 when
trump university agreed to this is
actually this is how you use quotes
exactly the air quote this is exactly
trump university agreed to pay a 25
million dollar settlement
two class actions and a fraud case for
defrauding its students sit down junior
you're responding to his tweet here yeah
now you didn't you didn't post you you
you did a screenshot of his tweet
yeah yeah because i don't i i would have
quote tweeted because yeah well the only
thing is like you know i've definitely
quote tweeted people before and then
their [ __ ] is deleted
so this is me capturing this oh
in time because that's one of the
reasons why you do a screen job yeah i
will do screenshots because also it's
like yeah if you want you can go easily
you know you could search downstream
junior or you can search a you know a
block of text in here and find what he
said and find his tweet
but i don't want to bring any more
traffic to his [ __ ] account oh i do
this is yeah i want to i want to get him
ratio like a [ __ ] that's fine
people will find if they want to do it
they can do it themselves this is just
me saying like all right i want to
capture this moment for this dumb
[ __ ]
well he calls you all the time he's
always yeah he calls me all the time so
it's like you really don't have to quote
tweet him you can yeah yeah it's like he
you know it just gives him more reason
to be like hey gabe i saw that you quote
tweeted my tweet why didn't you quote
tweet me right why didn't you quote you
screamed tweet me bro that's right
right right so donald trump jr tweets
this is this morning or yesterday
sometimes this was yesterday yesterday
20 some hours ago he tweets cancelling
student debt is a tax on the most
responsible people in the country which
is
absolutely [ __ ]
i just i can't i don't even know where
to start with this attacks what the [ __ ]
are you dumb [ __ ] talking about
what are what
are you talking about it's a tax the
people
the people who took the debt who paid
the debt took it knowing they were gonna
pay it the same way as the people who
are gonna get the ten thousand took the
debt knowing that they they didn't take
this debt going oh joe biden is
definitely gonna be president right in
six years and he's gonna relieve me of
ten thousand and let's and we gotta
remember that when you take a loan they
say great okay here's this amount of
money that we say you can use if you
don't use it you pay it back
or whatever based on whatever the
whatever the
contractual agreement is but in this
moment especially with student loans you
take an amount
it's going to be used for this thing
and then you have to pay it back right
the the [ __ ]
the
the school already got the money they
got the money okay they already took the
money right now you're paying back the
original lender right which in this case
is the government
right and they say okay well
that's that's the other that's the other
farce here is that that
colleges aren't gonna get they're gonna
lose money now because they're not gonna
get paid this money like right no
it's a loan from the government to pay
that's the that's the [ __ ] that's the
why it sucks yeah that's why they'll
have most of the time you've probably
already paid back that loan in full
because of the interest that you paid on
that loan right so now this whole like
we're gonna wipe the slate clean is just
like oh you're removing what you would
have actually paid in in interest on top
of that principle you know 10 20 30
years depending on however your loan
repayment plan was
so when somebody says it's a [ __ ] tax
on the most responsible clearly doesn't
know words no it's not
a tax does not understand a real tax on
the most responsible people is when
let's say trump decides to cut taxes for
the rich right and the middle class have
to pay for it wait well wait wait wait
you're saying you're saying that they
spread tax liability they they do wealth
district redistribution
or is that what you're saying well
i'm not saying but i'm saying you [ __ ]
yeah i i
goddamn you gave you and the truth um
don junior continues to say here in the
sweet forcing people who worked hard
it really is rich coming from donald jr
a people he he actually forms the
sentence forcing people who worked hard
which his dad took advantage of
hard-working people his entire life
stiffed them stiff the bill to repay
their loans for those who didn't have
the luxury of going to college
jesus christ his dad the guest the
government the federal government
[ __ ] forgave like 243
gazillion dollar i think it was a
million dollars yeah it's like a quarter
of a billion dollars they forgave them
yeah his family
yeah he he he gets to tweet on his
iphone today and and and
ostracized people who have trouble
paying their debts in this country even
though they're hardworking you know
single moms that have two jobs that even
though she went to school and she had to
drop out um and she still got [ __ ]
college debt because she went to school
and tried but couldn't couldn't make it
through
so now she's working two part-time jobs
maybe maybe even three a full-time job
and two part-time jobs to try to pay
this back you piece of [ __ ] don jr
says
have the luxury of going to college to
se and again he's using a lot of commas
i think him and his dad are on the same
uh uh well
yeah i mean the whole
run-on sends i'm horrible at writing
situations too [ __ ] uh two subsidized
people who wasted money
on worthless gender study degrees is a
slap in the face
oh my god okay so
this guy really does believe that the
only people who are going to receive
this benefit are lazy people who got a
gender study degree what in the [ __ ] is
he talking about this is the whole thing
of like oh look everyone who goes to
school you know blue-haired liberal
they're studying the arts or they're
studying gender equality or whatever it
is like they just say like oh if you're
this if you are you know on the left
side of the spectrum or you appear this
way
and it's an attempt to be a dig right
it's it's it's
it's uh generalizing a whole group to
say well they're all studying gender
studies and that's what they're doing
this is like
this reminds me of when rick scott said
i think it was
11 12 years ago he talked about how
uh people
you know are wasting their time on
receiving anthropology degrees right
um
he goes i think in florida he said
something along is like we don't need
any more anthropologists in the state
meaning like people are wasting their
time on getting anthropology degrees now
here's the thing i worked with his
daughter jordan scott okay talking about
rick scott yeah rick scott former former
florida governor now florida senator
i used to work with his daughter jordan
here's the kicker tony you know what she
got her degree in
what's that anthropology oh my god are
you kidding me you mean you mean to tell
me you mean to tell me that he knew that
and still said that
seems it seems and i can tell you this i
can tell you this i heard some crazy
stories
from that family that i
i'm not in a position to talk about but
i can tell you this much
his daughter
oh you are totally in a position you're
right in front of a microphone we got a
camera yeah but i don't want to say oh
that could get me in trouble but what i
will say is that i i worked with his
daughter and eve and he came to visit
the office once
uh and nobody ended up staying in the
office uh but
she was because he was coming yeah
because we found out he was coming like
oh [ __ ] that really [ __ ] that guy
but
other than outside of just being an
[ __ ] a human a terrible you know uh
just evil person
he is god he did not like him well
couldn't can you blame her really yeah i
mean if rick scott was your dad would
you like him
no i mean no one would i mean with a
laugh like
i mean when you're when you've got a
photo cruise like even ted cruz is dead
doesn't
yeah and his daughters don't like him
even though oh yeah i mean made a tick
tock about it too
no [ __ ] great
speaking speaking of crazy [ __ ] oh
god you juice like a truth social
it and it's it's a truth baby oh it's
the truth let me tell you truth in all
over the place here oh this is recent
yes yesterday well this is from this
morning oh my god and he had another one
about leaking did you see the leaking
one what is it is anal leakage or what
well i was like oh this sounds like a
bit of projection here but he had it he
had a post that was
find it find it we'll get a we'll get a
uh we're running low on time here for
the two hours but yeah we'll put it up
if we can find it this is from this
morning um he woke up and i guess i
guess he woke up scared and felt like a
caged animal yeah i'm gonna try to read
this but it is literally one sentence
folks
he's got it as one sentence
[ __ ] here we go take a deep breath
take a deep breath yeah right well it's
really not even about where you can
breathe because you can breathe at the
commas he's got so many of them but the
problem is it just makes him look really
stupid yeah well he's a staple genius
tony right stable genius
even the federal judge who was like this
isn't the correct court and you need to
learn how to write sentences sir yeah
i'm like what the [ __ ] who wrote this
someone with a legal degree approaches
john barron yeah they're still they're
still they still have a license to
practice law okay what was the name of
the person that was uh trustee the
trustee did we ever find out if that's a
real [ __ ] person i don't know
we need to figure that we need to track
that down okay so grandpa poopypants
here post on fraud social once one big
long scared run-on sentence he says even
though i am as innocent as a person can
be projection holy [ __ ] and despite my i
don't know why maya is i don't know why
i mean it's just because everything is
his i guess so my campaign being spied
on by the radical left and the fisa fisa
court in capital being lied to and
defrauded all of the many hopes and
scams and they were illegally placed on
me by very sick and demented people
and without even mentioning the many
crimes of joe and hunter biden all the
real and the great detail in the laptop
from hell
it looks more and more like the fake
news media is pushing hard for the
sleaze
to do something that should not be done
okay i can't really figure out what he
sees
well i think that maybe that's why
maybe that's why um
sleaze is trending laptop from hell is
trending yeah it has to be from this
crazy ass well they the trump family
called they always called laptop from
hell right like the text oh so that it's
like the so it's not about his laptop
it's like it's a laptop for help because
here's the thing that same phrase laptop
from hell was sent from don jr to sean
hannity on january 6th when he was
trying to get a hold of his dad and he's
like yo you we gotta [ __ ] figure the
[ __ ] out he was like focus on the you
know we'll lose everything you know if
we don't fix the situation laptop from
hell blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah
it's complete you know somebody is
whining they are projecting their own
insecurities and fear because supposedly
from what i've heard today
is that the affidavit was returned to
the uh they have returned the affidavit
to the judge in a redacted form so now
we're waiting on whether the judge will
allow for police because because the
judge asked them to do the redactions
like if you yeah if you want to publish
this or if you obviously release it then
it has to be redacted and then obviously
needs approval from the judge now the
the truth
truth post that i sent you
uh is he's talking about he says the
justice department and fbi are
leaking again quotes are they actually
leaking or they're not leaking like i
don't know i i don't why when you do air
quotes like that when you actually do
air like the air quotes yeah it means
the
opposite right of what's like when i
used university it's because they
weren't an accredited university and new
york the state had told trump
and trump university
that they had to be licensed they told
them repeatedly over years and years and
years and then did not do that
they don't exist yeah um but they
again in this in this fraud social post
the the former guy is saying the justice
department fbi or
air quotes leaking yep which would be
the opposite but that's not what he
means here at levels never seen before
and i did nothing wrong i don't what the
[ __ ] does that i don't i don't know when
i saw that i immediately was like wait
is he is he is he admitting to leaking
like his pants
like i don't know the leaky type i don't
know i don't know
i said i'll just it depends right but in
this moment
it seems like he's projecting
he might be admitting to something
much project but i think he's he's
beginning to freak out because you know
there are
these rumors swirling about this
redacted affidavit which probably won't
tell you much more than like donald
trump mar-a-lago
and then like legal search warrant are
gonna be the only words that are like
not covered up on this whole thing
you're gonna see like three words if
that at all right well uh speaking of
words and people who don't know how to
use them well
ben shapiro
um
would you take it student loan advice
from a guy who doesn't even know
how how
a woman's vagina works with the you know
the fluids like he went on this tirade
about [ __ ]
the song wet ass [ __ ] he bought a great
piece of wood right poplar wood right
from but he talked about how his wife
didn't yeah he's like i don't know she
doesn't get wet she didn't get wet
that's gross yeah my wife i can i try
really hard and can never
make her but would you take advice from
this guy but here he is no i would never
take advice from this guy because i mean
like hypothetically if i were talking
about like uh you know student debt here
you know like you've got interest rates
and compounding interest and you've got
a period of when you have to repay the
loan but it's like why would you take
out the loan if you've already got money
it's like you could be like you could be
like uh mitt romney and take a million
dollars out and then go to school and
just uh and just do it that way
can you read the tweet and can you read
the tweet in
in shapiro's voice that that would be
fantastic because that'll really give us
the effect that he was going for right
um i have a controversial idea about
paying off student loan debt don't take
out debt you will likely be unable to
pay off and don't ask others to pay off
your debts
that is not what is happening here you
dumb [ __ ] these people took
these loans thinking knowing that they
would have to pay them back
now like you said earlier a lot of these
people are very young individuals and do
not understand how interest rates work
how amortization works how compounding
interest works how forbearance works
what and when they'll be responsible how
many years do i have to pay these things
because they don't tell them that but
also people who try to work
back into the economy because this isn't
just 18 year olds that take student
loans this is dumb yeah there's people
in their 30s and 40s they try to
re-enter or they have to change careers
yeah and they go back to college to get
a degree in the career that they're
changing to and they have to take i
don't know loans right and remember like
even these people who are continuing
education because these people come out
after you know after school they don't
finish they don't complete they come
back they get the degree awesome good
for them
the other thing here to remember is that
when
you are going to school you take out
this loan right it's all a part of the
american dream right you're able to live
in a country where you're you know
you're given certain rights and you're
able to go to a school and uh you know
get an education and get that house and
get that dog and that red door you know
in front of you and all this stuff like
you're told you're told you will get
this american dream if you follow these
steps right get an education
start a start a family get a house
and then you'll be able to
retire and enjoy you know the family
that you have
this is one of those things where like
the republicans want to attack people
americans who are willing to put down
their name
as the person taking a loan out because
they believed in achieving certain
success in this american dream through
education and now they're saying ah you
guys are [ __ ] lazy asses
well uh steven points out something here
on on youtube shapiro took pp loans and
forgiven as well and i i don't know i
don't know if that's the truth or where
the number is but it sounds about right
because scary larry posted this and he
said ben shapiro never had to worry
about student loans because his rich
parents paid for him to go to ucla where
he majored in political science of all
things and harvard law and what a waste
of money because he obviously didn't
learn a god damn thing i
put in the god so thank you scary larry
for your
for your commentary there on ben shapiro
gabe we have reached the top of the
second hour when we do two hours every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
they all want us to go to three and
we're getting our audience there guys
so invite invite your friends invite
your family especially your trump
supporting family to come here and hang
out with me and real gabe and fake fake
apes here um every day on facebook so
invite them on facebook youtube twitter
twitch we're there every single weekday
on youtube so don't forget to subscribe
to the youtube channel remember uh
follow the tony michael's pod we're
gonna have the bonet of the week poll
it'll be on youtube and twitter don't
forget to download every single episode
every single weekday on apple spotify
google your favorite directory while
you're there leave us a great review it
would help us out we really appreciate
it also go visit the merch store store
dot d tony michaels dot com for your
doubt me merch we got steven join the
doubt me army yeah that's right that's
right and don't forget to support
pro-democracy speech today everywhere if
you want to support our show we have
much appreciated support.d
support.tonymichaelspod.com
it's down it's right it's right there
look at that
but you can also you can also go to the
qr the qr code that's here yeah there
you go if you want to use the qr code if
you're fancy enough to use a qr code you
can also go to the tonymichaels.com the
link is at the top if you'd like to
support our speech here on the tony
michaels podcast me and gabe much
appreciate it
don't forget tomorrow
same time
same place
we'll surf the tweety tweets to trendy
trends and we'll go through your vote
for the bonehead of the week until
tomorrow noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking